Hey everyone, it's Dr. Marcon and this is chapter 5 on the integumentary system.
So one of the organs in our integumentary system is the skin.
So we have the skin and the hypodermis.
The skin is our largest organ and it counts for about 7% of our body weight.
It can vary in thickness from anywhere between 1.5 to 4.4 millimeters.
It's divided into two very distinct layers.
We have the outermost or more superficial layer which is the epidermis and then we have
the dermis.
Now the hypodermis lies deep to the dermis.
It is composed of ariolar and adipose tissues.
Now the hypodermis is not part of the integumentary system but does share some of the skin's properties.
So here we see a slide of structure of the skin.
You can see the very distinct layers.
So here is the more superficial layer which is the epidermis and then we have the dermis
which is deep to the epidermis.
And we can see within the dermis there are two sublayers.
We have the papillary dermis and the reticular dermis.
Also within this slide we can see the hypodermis which is below the dermis which is again
composed of connective tissue as well as adipose tissue.
Then we can see some nervous structures, sensory nerve fibers, the free endings.
We can see lamellar corpuscles, we can see hair follicle receptors.
And then we can see some of the appendages of the skin.
We can see sweat glands, acrynslectric glands, erector p-line muscles, we can see oil glands
or sebaceous glands.
And then we see a hair follicle along with the hair root because we know that we do have
hairs within our skin.
So this is just a gross depiction of the skin and underlying tissues.
So the more superficial layer again is the epidermis and below that is the dermis.
Then we have the hypodermis again made up of that connective tissue as well as adipose
tissue.
We have some deep fascia and then deeper to that we have muscle.
Now we have five very important functions to the skin.
So first of all we have protection.
The skin provides protection because it cushions organs and protects from bumps, chemicals,
water loss and ultraviolet or UV radiation.
Also it helps with body temperature regulation.
We have our capillary network and sweat glands that help regulate heat loss.
It also functions with excretion so we lose urea, salts and water that are lost through
sweat.
Also it helps with the production of vitamin D. We have epidermal cells that will use ultraviolet
radiation to synthesize vitamin D.
And then we have sensory reception.
Within the skin we have sense organs that are associated with nerve endings.
So the first layer of the skin is the epidermis.
The epidermis is composed of keratinized stratified squamous epithelium.
Again we talked about the keratin being that protein that helps with waterproofing properties
of our skin.
So there are four main cell types within the epidermis.
We have the keratinocytes.
These are located in the stratum spinosum.
They produce keratin, that fibrous protein that we talked about earlier when we were talking
about epithelium.
We also have melanocytes.
They're located in the basal layer and they help manufacture and secrete the pigment melanin.
We also have tactile epithelial cells.
These are also located in the basal layer.
These are attached to our sensory nerve endings.
And then we have dendritic cells.
These are found in the stratum spinosum and are part of the immune system and they act
like macrophages.
Again those pac-man cells that kind of engulf any foreign tissue or foreign bodies.
First we're going to talk about keratinocytes.
These are the most abundant cell type in the epidermis.
They come from the deepest layer of the epidermis and produce keratin.
Keratin is a very tough fibrous protein, helps with the waterproofing properties of the skin.
Keratinocytes also produce antibodies and enzymes.
Now once they reach the skin surface, they die.
So keratinocytes at the skin surface are dead, they're dead gem.
So here are the layers of the epidermis.
So the deepest layer, we have the stratum basale, also known as the stratum germanotovum.
And then above that we have the stratum spinosum then stratum granulosum.
Stratum lucetum is only found in thick skin.
So thick skin being the skin on the palms of our hands and the soles are our feet.
And the most superficial layer is the stratum corneum.
So a pneumatic device that I like to use, I'm actually a really huge Star Trek fan.
So if you know Star Trek, there is actually a Star Trek with the character named Data.
And one of my favorite captains is Captain Picard.
This is the next generation.
So a good pneumatic that I like to use is BS.
So Brent Spiner gained lieutenant command.
Brent Spiner is the actor that plays data.
So Brent Spiner gained lieutenant command, helps you remember the layers of the epidermis
from the deepest layer to the more superficial layer.
Now mind you, this may become a bonus question, so I definitely study this very well.
So Brent Spiner, so B stands for stratum basale, the deepest layer, S spiner stratum spinosum,
which is above the stratum basale, then we have stratum granulosum gained, and then stratum
leucetum, which is only found in thick skin, lieutenant, and then stratum corneum command,
which is the most superficial layer.
So Brent Spiner gained lieutenant commander, a good pneumatic if you want to remember the
different layers of the epidermis from deep to superficial.
Now know that one of the bonus questions might ask you, name the layers from superficial
to deep, so make sure you pay attention to what the bonus question is asking you.
So here we see a slide of the different layers of the epidermis.
So below the epidermis we have the dermal layer, which contains, you can see here, our
dense irregular connective tissue.
And then we have the stratum basale, and the stratum basale is the deepest epidermal layer.
It's one row of actively mitotic stem cells.
Some newly formed cells become part of the more superficial layers.
And then occasionally you can see melanocytes as well as dendritic cells.
And then above the stratum basale, you will see the stratum spinosum.
This is made up of several layers of keratinocytes.
They're joined by desmosomes.
We talked about those structures that kind of join those cells together.
Cells contain thick bundles of intermediate filaments made of pre-caratin.
So this is before keratin is formed.
We have pre-caratin.
Then above the spinosum we have stratum granulosum.
This is one to five layers of flattened cells.
At this point, the organelles have started deteriorating.
The cytoplasm is full of laminar granules that release lipids.
And we have keratopiline granules.
And finally we have the most superficial layer that is the stratum corneum.
It's made up of about 23 layers of dead cells represented only by flat, membranous sacs filled
with keratin.
And within these cells we have glycol lipids in the extracellular space.
So the more superficial layer is basically the dead layer that is the stratum corneum.
Now not represented in this slide is the stratum leucetum.
The stratum leucetum is actually only found in very thick skin.
Again, the skin of the palms of the hands and the soles of the feet.
So here is a drawing, a figure of the different layers of the epidermis.
Again, you'll find different cells within the stratum base alleys such as melanocytes.
We'll talk about melanocytes in just a little bit.
They secrete a specific pigment called melanin.
Melanin is basically what gives us the coloring in our skin, some more darker than others.
The stratum spinosum, again several layers of keratinocytes.
And then the stratum granulosum, these, this layer contain cells whose organelles have
started deteriorating, started dying off.
And then finally we have the more superficial layer, the stratum corneum that contain dead
cells and are filled with that protein keratin.
So we're going to talk about the different layers of the epidermis first.
We're going to talk about the stratum base alley.
The stratum base alley is the deepest layer of the epidermis.
It is attached to the underlying dermis.
Cells here actively divide in order to kind of replace the more superficial cells.
We know that stratum base alley contains specific cells.
For example, they have tactile epithelial cells that are associated with sensory nerve
endings.
Also, again, they contain those melanocytes that we talked about that secrete the pigment
melanin that gives us our skin color.
And then here we see our stratum base alley that the deepest layer of the epidermis.
And just below the stratum base alley, we have our dermal layer.
Again, our dermis is made up of dense irregular connective tissue.
And there are different layers to the dermis.
We have the papillary dermis and the reticular dermis.
We see that the papillary dermis looks like it has these finger-like projections that
are going into the epidermis.
So if you see sort of these fingers, these are papilla.
These are the dermal papilla.
And these papilla make up the papillary dermis.
And then below the papillary dermis, we have the reticular dermis.
And we'll get into the dermis in just a little bit.
But on this slide, you kind of want to focus on the different layers of the epidermis,
especially in thick skin.
We have our stratum base alley here that have mitotically active cells.
We then have the stratum spinosum above the base alley, the granulosum above the spinosum.
And then finally, we have this sort of clear layer above the granulosum.
And that is the stratum lucetum.
You'll only see the stratum lucetum again in thick skin.
And then we have this very thick layer, the stratum corneum.
Again, these are dead cells that have a high amount of the protein keratin.
Next layer is the stratum spinosum.
It's the spiny layer.
The spiny appearance is caused by artifacts of histological preparation.
It contains thick bundles of intermediate filaments that resist tension and contain the protein
precaritin.
So this is precaritin before a keratin is formed.
Among the keratinocytes, our star-shaped dendritic cells are a type of macrophage and help function
in the immune system.
Again, they act like Pacman cells to kind of engulf any foreign debris or any pathogens
that might be found in the epidermis.
The next layer is the stratum granulosum.
Consists of a few layers of keratinocytes.
These keratinocytes will contain keratohilin granulins that help form keratin.
So from the precaritin, you'll need these granules to help form mature keratin or keratin
proteins.
Also there are laminar granules that contain the waterproofing glycolipid.
We know that granulosum above the stratum granulosum cells are too far from durable capillaries
to receive nourishment.
So the dermal capillaries, again, the epidermis is a vascular, but it receives nutrients from
the underlying dermis.
But the stratum granulosum is a little too far away from the dermal capillaries, so it's
not receiving the proper amount of nourishment and blood supply.
The stratum leucetum is a clear layer.
It occurs only in thick skin.
Again, you'll only find it in the palms of the hand and soles of the feet.
It's composed of a few rows of flat dead keratinocytes.
And then above leucetum, we'll find the stratum corneum, the horny layer.
It is composed of a thick layer of dead keratinocytes and thickened plasma membranes.
This is the most superficial layer.
It protects the skin against abrasion and penetration.
So here we see in detail the epidermal skin structure.
So here is another pneumatic that will help you remember the names of the different layers
in the epidermis.
So basically the spinning by granny is loose and corny.
For me, I'm a Star Trek fan.
So I like the pneumatic Brent Spiner Gains Lieutenant Commander, meaning he was promoted.
So whatever pneumatic you want to use, it'll help you remember the different layers within
the epidermis.
You can see a histological picture compared to a drawing or a figure representation.
So beneath the epidermis, we have the dermis.
The dermis is the second major region of the skin.
It is strong and flexible and has connected tissue.
It is richly supplied with blood vessels and nerves and has two very distinct layers within
the dermis.
We have the papillary dermis, which includes dermal papillary.
Again, these are finger-like projections coming from the dermis that kind of project into
the epidermis.
And then we have a reticular dermis, which is a deeper layer and makes up about 80% of
thickness of the dermis.
So the papillary dermis includes structures called the dermal papillae.
They help increase surface area for exchange of gases, nutrients, and waste.
Dermal papillae lie on dermal ridges.
The epidermal ridges or friction ridges are elevations of the dermal ridges.
These epidermal ridges are fingerprints.
They also increase the gripping ability of hands and feet.
So here is a picture of the epidermis and the dermis.
So within the dermis below our stratum, stratum-based alley, we have these finger-like projections
going into the epidermis.
This is our papillary layer.
So the papillary layer is the layer directly below the deepest layer of the epidermis, the
stratum-based alley.
So this layer, here is the papillary layer.
And underneath the papillary layer is the reticular layer, which makes up about 80% of
the dermis.
And this next picture shows you a better picture of the different layers of the dermis.
So again, you have these papilla, or dermal papilla, that make up the papillary layer
of the dermis.
And then you have this reticular layer just deep to the papillary layer.
And then we can see, you know, our dense irregular connective tissue, making up the different
layers of our dermis.
So the reticular dermis accounts for 80% of dermal thickness.
Again, made up of dense irregular connective tissue.
We have cleavage lines that are separations between collagen fibers.
And the collagen fibers, we know, give skin its strength.
Dermal lines are deep creases in palms, wrists, soles, fingers, and toes.
We know that the reticular dermis has a very rich nerve supply, has two vascular plexuses.
We have a dermal plexus, any sub-papillary plexus.
Blood vessels play a very important role in temperature regulation.
So here we can see the different ridges within our epidermis.
We know the epidermal ridges are just basically an elevation of the dermal ridges.
And we can see our flexure lines in our fingers, as well as in our palm.
If you ever go to a palm reader, these are the lines that they end up reading.
And then we do have cleavage lines in the reticular dermis.
So below the dermis, we have a layer called the hypodermis.
The hypodermis is not part of the skin, but it's a layer that is deep to the skin, and
it's also called superficial fascia.
We know that the hypodermis contains ariolar and adipose connective tissue.
The hypodermis is important because it anchors the skin to underlying structures and helps
insulate the body.
And we have different distributions of the hypodermis in males and females.
So how do we get our skin color?
We have three pigments that contribute to skin color.
We have melanin.
Melanin is the most important pigment made from tyrosine.
We know we have melanocytes that are located within the epidermis that produce melanin
and help contribute to the pigmentation of our skin.
Carotene.
Carotene is a yellowish pigment from carrots and tomatoes, and we have hemoglobin.
We talked about hemoglobin being that protein important for our oxygen transport with our
red blood cells.
Caucasian skin contains very little melanin because we don't, caucasians don't have that
pigment to make their skin darker.
This allows the crimson color of the blood to kind of show through the pale skin.
So that's why most caucasians have that pinkish color towards that skin, to their skin because
of the protein hemoglobin.
Along with the integumentary system, we have skin appendages.
Skin appendages are basically derivatives of the epidermis, and this includes hair and
hair follicles, nails, sweat glands, and sebaceous glands.
These help maintain body homeostasis.
So first, we're going to talk about nails.
Nails are basically a scale-like modification of the epidermis.
They're made up of very hard keratin, and we have different parts to nail.
We have the free edge.
There's the body.
There's the root of the nail.
There are the nail folds, and then we have the epinecium.
The epinecium is also known as the cuticle, and this is the part of the nail that we get
trimmed when we have a pedicura done, which is something I probably need to have done because
I haven't had one in a very long time.
So here we see the different structures of the nail.
Here is that free edge.
We have the nail plates, and then we have the epinecium, which is the cuticle.
This structure right here is the lunula.
It's sort of a half-moon-like structure that we see at the base of the nail plates, and
we can see that the nail bed is actually embedded within the fingers.
We have folds that kind of go over the nail plates, and then we see the tip of the finger,
the finger tip, the distal phalanx that makes up that fingertip.
Another appendage of the skin we're going to talk about is hair.
Hair are flexible strands of dead keratinized cells made up of hard keratin, which are tough
and durable, and there are chief parts of a hair.
We have the root of the hair, which is embedded in the skin, and then we have the shaft.
The shaft of the hair is the part of the hair that projects above the skin's surface.
Hair are flexible strands that are produced by hair follicles and consists of dead keratinized
cells.
So the hair that you see on your head that you hold in your hand, this is actually dead
keratinized cells.
Again, we have different regions of the hair.
We have the shaft of the hair.
This is where keratinization is complete, it consists of the dead keratinized cells, and
then we have the root of the hair that's embedded in the skin where keratinization is
still ongoing.
Hair follicles will fold down from the epidermal surface into the dermis, and then we have
specialized smooth muscles called erector pealae muscles.
Erector pealae muscles are bundles of smooth muscle cells that help pull the hair upright
in response to cold temperatures, or sometimes in response to fear, like an upcoming exam
or an upcoming quiz that Dr. Markon might be giving you or a surprise exam that Dr. Markon
might be giving you, which she won't because she wouldn't do that, or if there's a ghost
in the room or something scary on TV, again, these are erector pealae muscles, erector pealae
muscles respond to that and help bring the hair standing up and give you those goose pimples.
Hair has three concentric layers of keratinized cells.
We have a centralized core called the medulla.
We have the outer layer called the cortex, which surrounds the medulla, and then we have
the cuticle, which is the outermost layer.
So here we see that inner medulla, and then we have an outer layer, which is the cortex.
So if you follow this line, we have the outer cortex, and then surrounding the cortex will
be the cuticle.
So this is just a diagram of a cross-section of a hair within its follicle.
We can see the follicle under the microscope.
So at the central portion of the hair, we have the medulla, and then surrounding the
medulla, the inner medulla, we have the cortex, and surrounding the cortex is the cuticle.
So hair follicles will extend from the epidermis into the dermis.
In the hair follicle, you'll have the hair bulb.
This is a deep, expanded end of the hair follicle, and then you have the root plexus, which is
a knot of sensory nerves around the hair bulb.
So here is a diagram of the hair bulb of the follicle.
So here we'll see a layer of dermal papillos, sort of like a finger-like projection there.
We have, again, when we saw a cross-section of it, the inner medulla, and then the outer
cortex, and then the cuticle of that hair follicle.
And then we'll see maybe melanocytes at the hair bulb of the hair follicle.
Here again is a histone side of the hair bulb, where we can see that dermal papilla.
And then the innermost layer being the medulla.
And then around the medulla we'll see the cortex, and then the cuticle of the hair root.
The wall of the hair follicle is a connective tissue root sheath, and also an epithelial
tissue root sheath.
We talked about the erector pealae muscles.
Erector pealae muscles are a bundle of smooth muscles.
So if they are a smooth muscle, they are under involuntary control.
So hair will stand erect when the erector pealae contracts.
So we have different types and growth of hair.
We have villus hairs.
These are body hairs of women and children.
There are terminal hairs, which is the hair of the scalp, as well as hair of the axillary
and pubic area that occurs after puberty.
And then there will be hair thinning and baldness due to aging.
And it is a sex-linked chromosome, so we'll get male patterned bat baldness.
So other accessory structures within the integumentary system, there are sebaceous glands.
Sebaceous glands occur over the entire body, except for the palms and soles.
Sebaceous glands actually secrete sebum, which is an oily substance.
The types of glands that secrete sebum are a simple aviolar glands.
So remember we talked about simple glands being just one docked and not branching.
Aviolar have that spherical shape to them.
These sebaceous glands secrete through holochrin secretion, meaning the entire cell will break
up to form the secretion.
And most sebaceous glands are associated with a hair follicle.
Some functions of sebum, it helps collect dirt.
It also softens and lubricates hair and skin.
So it's an oily substance that kind of helps lubricate your hair and skin.
So here we see the glands of the skin.
So we can actually see a hair within the follicle.
And then sort of surrounding it, we can see these sebaceous glands next to the hair follicle.
Other types of glands are sweat glands, which are pseudo-riferous glands that are widely
distributed on the body.
We know that sweat is actually a blood filtrate.
It's made up of 99% of water with some salts and contains traces of metabolic waste, so
about 2% of urea.
So here we can see some sweat glands located within the dermis.
You can see all these cells that make up the sweat glands within the dermal layer.
So we have two types of sweat glands, we have an ecarin or mericrine sweat gland.
These are the most numerous, and these produce true sweat.
And then we have apocrine glands.
These are confined to axillary, anal, and genital areas and produce a special kind of
sweat.
It produces a musky odor, which helps attract a mate.
These are the pheromones that a lot of people talk about that kind of can attract another
person or sometimes in animals.
They signal information about a person's immune system and contribute to the major histocompatibility
complex.
And then we have serum minus glands and mammary glands.
These are also modified apocrine glands.
So when we talk about skin, we want to talk about common emergencies associated with skin.
We want to talk about burns.
So burns are caused by heat, chemicals, explosions, electricity, and solar radiations.
Critical burns can be life threatening, and quite immediate medical attention can cause
breathing difficulty, especially if it covers more than one body part.
Burns are emergencies when they affect the head, neck, hands, feet, and genitals, and
also their emergencies if there are burns to a child or older adult.
So either they're really young or they're really old other than minor burns.
Burns are classified by severity.
First degree burn occurs when only the upper epidermis is damaged.
So it's not as severe.
Second degree burns when you have the upper part of the dermis as well as the epidermis
is also damaged and you can have blistering or blisters that appear.
But the skin can heal with very little scarring.
However, third degree burns, this will consume the entire thickness of the skin, meaning all
the layers.
Burned areas may appear white, red, or blackened, and you can either have great pain if the nerve
endings are destroyed, or it could be painless, sorry, great pain, or if the nerve endings
are destroyed, the burn may be painless.
So here we actually can see the different types of burns.
First degree burn again, only occurring within the epidermis.
The second degree burn affecting both the dermis and the epidermis.
And then third degree burns occurring throughout the full thickness of the skin.
In order to estimate the extent of burns, we use what's called the rule of nines.
We associate a percentage to a specific body part, for example, the front part of the upper
limb accounts for 4.5%, whereas the anterior trunk accounts for 18%.
And we add this up to kind of figure out the percentage of the body that has been burned.
So this is called the rule of nines.
When we talk about skin, we also want to talk about skin cancer, and there are different
types of skin cancer.
First type of skin cancer is basal cell carcinoma.
Basal cell carcinoma is the least malignant and the most common.
So again, it will affect the basal cell layers within the epidermis.
Squamous cell carcinoma arises from keratinocytes of the stratum spinosum, and then we have melanoma.
Melanoma is a cancer of the melanocytes, and it is the most dangerous type of skin cancer.
It has a high rate of metastasis, meaning it spreads to other organs and can have a very
poor prognosis.
So here we see an example of basal cell carcinoma.
Here is a squamous cell carcinoma, and here is a dark mole or a dark lesion indicative
of melanoma.
So that is why when we have patients, we want to make sure, especially if they are prone
to skin cancer, we want to check if they have any moles.
We also want to check our ABCs when it comes to moles.
So A, we want to check for appearance.
If there are any changes in appearance, B, we want to look for borders, whether or not
they have distinctive borders or irregular borders.
C, we want to check for color, and whether or not there are darker color or reddish color
or if there is any change in color.
And D, we want to check for diameter, whether or not the mole has gotten bigger or has increased
in diameter.
So check your ABCDs for moles to kind of do a quick check for melanoma or skin cancer.
So we know that the epidermal layer will develop from embryonic ectoderm, however the dermis
and hypodermis will develop from mesoderm.
Milano sites develop from neural crest cells within the fetus.
The fetal skin is well formed after the fourth month, and then after or at five to six months,
the fetus is covered in downy hairs called lanugo.
We have fetal sebaceous glands that produce the vernix casioso.
So sort of this cheesy thick layer that you'll see once the baby has been born.
Throughout life, middle to old age, the skin will thin out and become less elastic, meaning
the fibers that are usually predominant within our skin are no longer being produced as
much as we get older.
Also skin can start showing the harmful effects of environmental damage, especially for those
who are sun worshipers, who didn't wear sunscreen when they were younger, who got forbid, you
know, went into those tanning beds.
I'm probably guilty of them when I was a teenager.
That was the cool thing to do to sit in tanning beds before a dance or before prom.
And I do regret it because those are basically cancer beds.
They give a very high dose of UV radiation to your skin, and you can definitely, you
know, after prolonged usage, could cause cancer.
Also, you know, if you expose yourself to that much sun and UV radiation, you start getting
wrinkles and you start looking like you're aging early.
So if you can, try to avoid the sun between the hours of ten and two.
And if you have to be out, make sure you're wearing a hat or some sort of protective gear
to protect your skin, because honestly, once you get old, you know, you can't stop the
wrinkling process.
You can't stop the aging process.
So while you're young, take care of your skin now.
Also when you get older, skin inflammations do become more common.
Okay, guys.
So that is chapter five on the integumentary system, on the skin and the accessory appendages.
And that is it for the first part of this unit.